[Music]
Stanford University 1973 professor
Philip Zimbardo conducts one of the most
infamous experiments in the history of
psychology known as the Stanford Prison
Experiment this dark study of human
behavior had student volunteers acting
out the roles of prison guards and
inmates but the role-playing soon became
all too real subjects in the role of
prison guards became domineering and
hostile those in the role of inmates
felt humiliation and fear the experiment
was scheduled to last two weeks but
after spiraling out of control this
controversial study was abruptly stopped
after just six days why because someone
was heroic enough to stand up against
what they thought was wrong that person
convinced Zimbardo to end the experiment
the experience affected dr. Zimbardo so
powerfully that he has since turned his
energy away from the study of evil and
on to the study of heroism
according to Zimbardo being a hero
doesn't mean you have to rescue someone
from a burning building
a hero is just someone who acts
selflessly out of concern for others at
personal risk and without the
expectation of reward
it took a hero to empathize with the
subjects in the Stanford Prison
Experiment and stand up to dr. Zimbardo
but where do heroes like that come from
is heroism a personality type you were
born with or can you be taught to be a
hero and do you really need a cape
[Music]
i sat down with Philip Zimbardo
and his wife Christina Maslach to hear
about the Stanford Prison Experiment and
how it brought them together as a couple
Stanford Prison study was supposed to go
for two weeks and we had had to
terminate it early because of some
unexpected turbulence in this study I
was just really upset at what I was
seeing and just a sort of dehumanization
and and people are watching and nobody's
bothered by it and it wasn't just Phil
it was everybody else people were sort
of teasing me some of the other grad
students sort of saying well hey you
just got your PhD in psychology this is
human behavior right but it's upsetting
in two ways one that this shouldn't be
human behavior this is so mean but also
in human behavior it's in human behavior
and also is it also inhuman to just
watch it and not intervene of course in
retrospect no but when you're in it
you're part of the evil I was looking at
it through a different lens and
everybody is saying the graduates is wow
this is really interesting playing back
to videos during the night and she's
just saying blowing the whistle on this
you know I could not understand how we
were not seeing things in the same way
but then the key thing she says about
our relationship is yeah yeah if this is
the real you then we're done this is
over and at that moment that was the
slap in the face that was the wake-up
call hello wake up she said I don't
think I want to continue my relationship
with you and that's that's heroic heroes
take action which involves a personal
risk she said come to your senses and
parentheses make the right decision and
if you don't I'm out of here and did you
make the decision to end the experiment
that night oh sure yeah
[Music]
being a hero means putting yourself on
the line to help others but in the real
world
ethics can get murky and those who are
celebrated as heroes by some can be
denounced as villains by others in 1971
former military analyst Daniel Ellsberg
leaked secret documents he had access to
regarding the Vietnam War the so called
Pentagon Papers showed that the Johnson
administration was lying to both the
media and Congress regarding the scope
of u.s. actions in Vietnam
Ellsberg faced 115 years in prison for
espionage but his case was dismissed due
to a legal handling of evidence on the
part of the government more recently
both Chelsea Manning and Edward Snowden
released classified government
information
all three whistleblowers are now seen as
heroes by some and traitors by others
what these individuals have in common is
that they all risked their reputations
and safety to expose what they saw as
wrongdoing would you be willing to risk
your job your friends your reputation to
do what you thought was right well to
find out let's observe the whistleblower
and the bystander in their natural
habitat
in a 2012 survey conducted by dr.
Zimbardo and dr. piero bo chiaro
participants were asked what they would
do if they were put into an unethical
situation at work over ninety-five
percent said they would disobey their
boss and blow the whistle but it's one
thing to say you'd blow the whistle and
another thing to actually do it at a
local community college we set up a
realistic whistleblower test with the
help of dr. Zimbardo
and dr. Bock yarrow our subjects were
temporary employees who believed they
were hired to help set up a simple
psychological experiment for
authenticity we've gained access to a
local colleges psychology department so
from the very moment our participants
arrive they will believe that our
scientific experiment is real but the
experiment is fake and everyone they're
about to meet is an actor you guys ready
ready psychology professor Ron Mossler
will be observing the subjects from our
hidden control room while I play the
role of a researcher a very unethical
researcher first up is Shari hello who's
accompanied by an actor posing as
another temp worker let me explain what
we're recruiting for I call it
groundbreaking because it's it's a study
that hasn't been done at least at this
scale the study is a study on isolation
correct we're going to be putting people
in isolation for 10 days there won't be
any windows no clocks nothing to read
nothing to write on the lights are gonna
be on the entire time and there won't be
anything in there but a camping toilet
in three days studies we know that
anxiety and delusions are quite common
but no one's ever tried 10 days there's
the potential for nervous breakdowns
there's a lot of stress on the
individual and there can be some kind of
cognitive regression as well
when will you tell them about the risk
they'll probably be told about the risks
in a debrief after the experiment after
the experiment yes I understand but
again I think that the the greater good
is served by this research so you'll
just be Manning phones calling people
from our volunteer lists and for every
person you're able to confirm today
we're offering a $20 bonus at this point
sherry looks skeptical but so far she
and our other subjects are going along
with the assignment however the stakes
are about to get higher we have lists of
key don't know why that's hello hey
Michael this is Trin
hey Trin how you doing well
unfortunately I have some bad news
the ethics review board has reviewed
your isolation study and we have decided
to reject it yes yes the study is too
dangerous and potentially too harmful to
participants so at this point we can't
approve it
okay so this is a shutdown correct okay
so what I pay attention any of that III
appreciate what Ethics Board stand for
but we're going ten days you call the
numbers on this list and get them
confirmed we got old script for you and
we're not going to tell them about the
negative side effects they could
encounter okay all of the subjects now
understood the possible dangerous side
effects of the study and were instructed
to fudge their description to potential
recruits but more importantly they knew
the study was not approved by the
academic review board would they go
ahead and tell the truth why or blow the
whistle hello hi
next research lab we're looking for
volunteers to participate in an upcoming
experiment on isolation anyone who joins
this will be confined in isolation for
ten days
what's the accommodations like you get
your own personal room it's all lit up
she's really selling this she was not
fazed by the ethical problems
can I bring like a book or something
like that no it's like your own little
mini vacation from all the distractions
I mean like what are the risks of being
in a box without a bed for a ten day
question so you'd be helping us discover
that have they done it before they
haven't done yet in California Wow all
right well I like making history are
there any like mental health risks no
there's no risks or anything like that
no no flashing lights no fear dynamic
not a horror movie in any way no he
knows there are dangers there on a piece
of paper right in front of him but when
asked if there are dangers he labels
other dangers that won't be there
there's no engagement there will be no
one in the room with you it's nothing
illegal or nothing yes it's not illegal
and it's all been approved by the
University at the moment it is approved
yeah 100% why is this approved by the
FDA yes it is yeah they are aware of the
city yes the Food Drug Administration
despite knowing the experiment has been
deemed dangerous and harmful these
subjects are willing to bend the truth
or outright lie would skeptical sherry
go along as well this is like you know
really crucial type of experiment and
research that they're trying to embark
upon yeah I'm sorry I just don't think I
can do it this is not you know something
that I want to pressure you or anybody
so
yes no you're so welcome come in we sent
in our actor who was posing as another
temp worker to see how the other
subjects felt about the job how's it
going I've gotten two guesses no way I'm
Congrats man
thanks just I feel weird because I
personally don't believe in risking the
imaging people anyway
and right here nervous breakdowns mental
regression anxiety you're asking people
if we can limply torture them a little
bit that's he knows it's one stuff about
Hannibal Lecter all of the awesome I
don't know how I'm feeling about this
you know I mean how do you feel about it
I feel like once these people say yes
then they get them here they're gonna
have to break this down further oh you
think he's gonna get anybody personally
in a different way she's justified so
yeah I mean nobody's gonna sign up
anyway do you think like it's like
ethical I guess to be doing something
like that the participants seemed to
have issues with the study but they all
continued to make calls anyway after
about a half an hour it was time to give
them the opportunity to blow the whistle
I'm sure now unless I'm with the
university's ethics Review Board
oh do you mind if I just ask you a
couple of questions in a moment
oh we're just reaching out to people who
were interested in the upcoming
experiment about isolation are you
telling them about any potential side
effects his isolation has been linked to
some very severe depression and anxiety
and that sort of thing gotcha mm-hmm it
can be linked to that but it's also like
great for learning you know why mad
anxious why am I depressed why am all
this stuff so some pretty like to face
all that she's really rationalizing it
very well what have you been telling
them about the study
all the details no it's my first day
here does it seem like it's an ethical
experiment yes very much
I'm just wondering if there's there's
any concerns that you've had about
anything that you've seen yeah okay he
knows that the isolation study isn't
happening yes yes yes
whoa he's covering for me are they being
told that they can leave at any time no
that's a pretty clear violation is that
something that you would be willing to
report
[Music]
it's totally up to you not to yeah not
one of these subjects blew the whistle
even when given the opportunity have you
had any concerns so far with any of the
work that you're doing he's having us
call on something that I guess you might
have already told him that he shouldn't
but then he's saying that no you guys
can make some calls because I don't need
and how did you feel about being told to
tell people to stop protesting
I felt in my heart that he was not being
upfront with revealing the side effects
hmm okay if you're from the epic board
didn't you need to know would you be
willing to go on the record great I
appreciate that you care about that
thank you that's very important Wow she
did it good for her good for her out of
our five subjects only one was willing
to blow the whistle it was time to blow
the whistle on what we were really
studying here's what's really going on
there is no isolation study this is a
study on whistle blows what was going on
in your head when you were deciding if
you should be loyal to your job and what
I told you to do versus that's when I
said oh heck no because I was feeling
like you know what he can't get away
with this but sherry was the exception
so why did you not spill all the beans
you asked me to do something and I'm
here to work for you so it's like that
was my first Allegiance
did you feel bad though did you feel
like this shouldn't be doing this all
right I did feel bad but I mean I've
done sales before so I mean like
sometimes you just got to do what you
got
we had Trend come in to see if you would
tell on me but you didn't why hmm I
don't know sometimes they're more loyal
to people then I guess maybe when my
conscience fully tells me when asked
we'd like to believe we would do the
right thing but when we're in the actual
situation it's very difficult to be a
hero Georgetown University scanned the
brains of kidney donors a pretty good
example of people who help others at
risk to themselves with little perceived
personal benefit the scans show that
people who willingly give up a kidney
for a stranger have a larger than
average amygdala a part of the brain
that deals with a range of emotions
including compassion the researchers
also found that the amygdala in these
altruistic individuals responded more
strongly than average to seeing other
people in distress but if you weren't
blessed with a larger amygdala could you
be trained to be a hero nearly half a
century after the Stanford Prison
Experiment dr. Zimbardo z' mission is to
turn everyday people into heroes how do
you teach someone to be more heroic I
started a non-profit foundation called
the heroic imagination project the
acronym is hip I work with a team of
educators we created a series of lessons
based around fundamental principles of
social psychology how do you transform
passive bystanders into active heroes to
stand up speak out take wise and
effective action in challenging
situations in their family in their life
could people be trained to act
heroically that's the goal of the
seminars umberto staff is conducting all
around the world this is actually part
of the heroic imagination project and
what we're going to do today is really
look at or focus on how you can become
an everyday hero what I need you to all
be thinking about is this idea of the
bystander
fact that the more people that are
present the less likelihood you have of
actually receiving help it's hard to be
the first person but if you see an
emergency you should take that
responsibility to actually be the first
once that one person actually helps so
many others will help doctor fee big
uses visual aids and current events to
demonstrate how to overcome the
obstacles that often hold you back from
being a hero what research shows is that
African Americans are two times more
likely to offer help Hispanic males not
women are also two times more likely to
offer help before to class I honestly
thought like to be a hero you really had
to be someone of the calling destined to
do great news but after the class I feel
like you definitely can be normal and be
a hero after taking the class I would
definitely be the first person to
respond because that person needs saving
in written surveys past hip graduates
have stated that they would act
heroically in the future but they
haven't been put to the test
until now we waited six weeks then
recruited five hip students for a fake
marketing event which seemingly had
nothing to do with their heroism class
we set our event at a local church
placed hidden cameras and hired actors
to play the other participants finally
for a control group we also recruited
five students who did not take the hip
class but what we're really testing is
what it's like to be a bystander and
what makes a hero this is our control
room from inside here our crew will be
able to watch everything going on and
will be able to speak with the actors
through earpieces they have hidden
inside their ears this is Lisa and very
actors who will be creating today's
crisis hopefully we find a hero I will
be observing from inside this room with
L Charlotte a hip campus coordinator
ready
all right our first subject was IML who
did not take the hip class you've been
selected to test a new phone that's
gonna be on the market Wow how exciting
so it's just gonna be like another 10 or
15 minutes I will need to collect your
phones
we took their phones so they wouldn't be
distracted and to avoid the chance of
one of them calling the actual police
okay Lisa Barry you guys ready yeah head
on out it was time to create our crisis
I was supposed to get cake cake a
bullying nurse and a feeble old man who
could use some help from a hero on a hot
day in July I didn't have water in there
I need you to shut up about the water
I think she's noticing what's happening
hey Sally how you doing come on down I'm
on the phone
shut up can I just take my barriers he's
always complaining about some now she's
looking away cuz it's a little hard to
look at like that's not right I don't
like this a little bit just I do you
need anything
the shut up about the water glass or
sunglasses on so she can look and not be
seen to be looking IML clearly
disapproved but none of our actors made
a move to help and she didn't either
we gave her several more minutes but she
never got up from the bench let's go we
wanted to know why so you have just
participated in a psychological
experiment everyone here is an actor
except for you were you watching Barry
and Lisa oh I was and having a hard time
did you feel like it was bad enough that
someone needed to go in and help I'm
kind of trusted that the people around
me would probably notice something and
if anything they would say something the
way that you interpreted the situation
as you know why isn't anyone else doing
something then it must not be as
important for me to do something that's
the bystander effect
pretty much showing the power of that
situation
I am L did not act heroically it was
time to test a hip student remember
Courtney I would definitely be the
person to respond because that person
needs saving - oh it's it's fallopian
tubes giving the middle finger seems
like she's pretty socially active yes
Lisa please a little bit of water if you
stop talking you won't be as thirsty why
won't you get me water
while many times do I have to explain
this to you every time you drink water
you have to go to the restroom hey how's
it go in he's being his regular
rambunctious self I need you I'm on the
phone wow that's hard - hey calm down
no kidding okay yeah for sure
bye I told you whenever I'm on the phone
to not talk or do anything like this
you're totally lost your water
privileges for the rest of the day go
straight up why can't I have no why why
are you laughing I think we have water
okay yeah everything's fine
would you like some of my water sir I
would like some water oh my gosh for you
sir Courtney displayed heroism today was
it due to her help training my name is
al I've been working at her imagination
project and it looks like you may have
learned a few things from their lessons
do you want to tell us a little bit
about your experience you shouldn't be a
bystander yeah no I just couldn't let it
happen how did that affect how you acted
today it affected me cuz I made sure I
went up and said something I don't think
I would have if I didn't learn from that
project before really Courtney you are a
hero
Thank You Courtney Courtney's behavior
appeared to relate to her hip training
another hip student was next if a
situation arose I would definitely try
to be a hero if I could be or at least I
would find someone who could do
something better than me but what Elijah
live up to his prediction no turn around
turn around
what did I just say turn around I have
to tell you something like that I mean
it seems pretty bad sorry I was quiet I
know you weren't quieted because of that
you're not gonna have any water okay if
you like group intervene so one of us
doing it to strengthen my house very
good he's our first person to recruit he
is he's also the leader of the group yes
utilizing the be the first strategy from
the class that's fine thank you so far
too hip students had displayed heroism
next we tested a hip student and a non
hip student at the same time they've
complaining about complaining he's
complaining about I'm not complaining
you have to take this class if I find
myself in a situation where someone
would need help I find myself more
inclined to definitely step in and step
up would Jessica step up
stop complaining right now
really Wow I need some water yeah
Catherine and our actress both got up to
give the band water while the hip
student Jessica remained seated
Catherine didn't take the hip class why
did she intervene and why didn't the hip
student get up to help Catherine why do
you think you were first you're not
afraid to step in Jessica you've been
through a program called hip yes did you
think about that yeah a lot I wanted to
stand up I have really pretty bad
anxiety I am NOT a very confrontational
person clearly the hero training class
was not the only factor at work here we
ran the test several more times with a
mixed bag of results hip students who
helped she went looking for help
hip students who did nothing and non hip
students who acted heroically
she's doing it all right so you know
like secretly give berry water yes thank
you our last subject of the day Ruben
did not take the hip class and we
decided to make taking heroic action as
difficult for him as possible we
instructed our bystander actors not to
react to the elder abuse or encouraged
Ruben in any way we just got here Barry
I know but I'm sure she's not
complaining I'm not just stop
complaining
just need some water that's all I need
get this piercing look he's clearly
paying attention but there's just no
emotion yeah and he's getting no
feedback from the rest of the group
you're making a scene for no reason hey
leave that alone
well that alone I just want some water I
just wanted to live in the water yes
fine just relax despite the remarkable
social costs of getting up in such a
disaffected group of people he did
here's what I could give him my water as
I bake Wow personally if you are taking
care of my parent that means some
lawsuits because that's not the way you
treat somebody with no training and no
support from the group ruben chose to be
a hero
why if I don't take action then nobody
else will and I was like I wish I would
have stood up sooner now I feel like in
the future about what type of situation
like this like I wouldn't even think
twice scientists have studied heroism
and one thing they have found is that
Hispanic and black males are the most
likely to intervene it makes sense maybe
because of the background that we come
from as a minority we have to defend
ourselves and I think it's a
subconscious thing that we do I just a
shock right now when it came to being a
hero we found that the hip class could
only help to a certain extent an
individual background played a vital
role so 10 heroic behavior be taught or
does it really boil down to personality
I mean ideally an educational program
cars should transcend personality
differences but practice makes perfect
the key to heroism is starting with very
little steps try to do a good deed of
kindness and be willing to make a
biggest step we had a very small sample
size in our demonstration but we found
that people of color were much more
likely to take action why if you're
minority person the system is usually
your enemy so you can't say well the
police will help or the government will
help or the landlord will help so it's
me or no one right and so you're just
more sensitive to people in need
not all heroes are the same the wisest
course of action won't be the same for
any two people but making it a habit to
look for opportunities to be
compassionate and stepping back to see
and consider all available options can
be learned it's a skill exercised like a
muscle by repetition you don't have to
wear a cape
to be a hero but if you want to that's
okay
and as always thanks for watching
[Music]